these days we have 24-hour news the
sound bites never stop and the wars
never stop Iraq Afghanistan Palestine
this film is about the war You Don't See
drawing on my own experience as a war
correspondent it will look mainly a
television concentrating on the most
popular channels in America and Britain
the film will ask what is the role of
the media in rapacious Wars like Iraq
and Afghanistan why do many journalists
beat the drums of War regardless of the
lives of governments
and how are the crimes of War reported
and Justified when there are crimes
a pioneer of modern propaganda was this
man Edward Bernays
Bernays invented the term public
relations he wrote the intelligent
manipulation of the masses is an
invisible government which is the true
ruling power in our country
he was part of a secretive group called
the U.S Committee on Public Information
set up in 1917 to persuade reluctant
Americans to join the war in Europe
Edward Bernays and Walter live and go to
Woodrow Wilson and say look man if
you're going to enter into this war we
are going to need to sell this war to
the American people
and so Wilson institutes and creates the
first modern propaganda Machinery it was
actually quite brilliant in its
conceptualization so that the best way
to persuade people is to grab them by
their emotions by their unconscious and
instinctual urges let's not bother with
pumping out facts let's scare the hell
out of people
a picture of the Statue of Liberty in
tatters crumbled into the New York
Harbor with German planes flying around
it
a picture of the world being gobbled up
by the bloody hands of a gorilla wearing
a German Helmet so you know it's not
about facts anymore
the facts don't matter
for Edward Bernays public relations was
like a war on people on bending their
will
he persuaded women to smoke at a time
when smoking in public was not
considered ladylike
[Music]
he convinced a group of debutants to
parade along Fifth Avenue holding up
Lucky Strike cigarettes as symbols of
women's liberation
to his Delight the Press called these
torches of freedom
what he was interested in doing was
creating an association between a
product in this case cigarettes and the
desire for women's liberation
it worked in the sense that it got lots
of news coverage
it worked in the sense that women
started smoking publicly and in fact
smoking became a symbol of the new woman
of the emancipated woman
[Music]
thank you
Iraq March the 20th 2003 the creation of
Illusions and the selling of Ward come a
long way since Edward Bernays
the selling of this Invasion depended on
the news media to promote a series of
illusions
like the link between Saddam Hussein and
9 11.
this is the Pentagon which spends almost
a billion dollars a year just on
Advertising recruiting propaganda
the selling of War
their Pentagon contracts with news
organizations in terms of how to
manipulate the news their Pentagon
officials involved in press releases
that go to the the media in which
intelligence is used to manipulate
public opinion which is a violation of
the charter of any intelligence
organization then you have retired
generals who serve as press spokesman
for all the networks and they're it's
never revealed which military-industrial
firms they work for
Central to this is the co-opting and
spinning of a media regarded as the
freest in the world
Showdown Iraq if America goes to war
turn to MSNBC and the experts if we
journalists including myself it right
from the get-go from the opening part
it started asking the kind of tough
digging aggressive questions we should
have been asking and doing our reporting
rather than just being kind of
stenographers
go to a briefing have an official say
something print in the paper next day if
we had done our job I do think a strong
argument can be made that perhaps we
would not have gone to war
the attack on Iraq was sold by these two
men
the blueprint for the invasion was this
military Doctrine called Shock anore
designed to paralyze the country and
Destroy food production water supply and
other civilian infrastructure
the effect will be similar to the
dropping of the atomic bombs on Japan
this was terrorizing people on a grand
scale and it will be covered up by
deception in massive amounts
but this was not how it was reported at
the time
scores of American reporters have now
joined U.S military units in Kuwait as
part of the pentagon's effort to make
any war with Iraq but the Pentagon calls
a media friendly campaign a new word
embedding entered media language and the
planning for the invasion
most of the reports that viewers saw
came from within a system in which media
organizations agreed to certain
conditions laid down by the ministry of
Defense in London and the Pentagon in
Washington
at the time that our forces crossed into
Iraq we had some 700 reporters embedded
throughout our military formations
embedding was important
for that Conflict for a number of
reasons
one being that we knew we were going up
against an enemy that was somewhat
masterful at misinformation
disinformation we have a number of
correspondents in bed with our troops
across the region very deeply embedded
in a personal way with the Marine that
he's traveling with I love this
expression for the Iraq War the embedded
journalists well too many journalists
have been in bed with the administration
on a variety of issues I would say 80 to
90 percent of what you read in a
newspaper is officially inspired if
they're covering the intelligence
Community for example and they become
critical of the CIA or a major
intelligence organization they're going
to lose their sources if they become
critical of the Pentagon it's going to
be very difficult to get into the
Pentagon to deal with official military
sources so I think journalists like to
be part of the game part of the inside
crowd and therefore the conventional
wisdom uh is the best wisdom
[Music]
24-hour news in particular is a system
that is the most easy to manipulate
24-hour news is a giant Echo chamber so
that's why for example Basra was
reported as having fallen 17 times
before it actually fell and yet for our
news when you're reporting it for the
seventh time in that chain of 17 times
when the city has fallen falsely
the fact that it's been wrong the
previous seven times just doesn't matter
American armor is moving at will across
whole swathes of Baghdad this is this is
regular reporting for the BBC from
Baghdad he described the arrival of the
Americans as a Liberation people have
come out welcoming them holding up these
signs this is an image taking place
across the whole of the Iraqi Capital
today but it was not happening across
the rest of Iraq
this was another illusion
the toppling of the Statue of Saddam
Hussein was seized upon by the invading
Force as a target of opportunity
what was not news was a U.S army
investigation
describing how they exploited what they
called a media circus
there are almost as many reporters as
Iraqis says the report
it was an American psyops officer who
ordered the statue brought down
the resulting TV pictures gave no sense
of the bloody conquest of Iraq that was
already well underway
you know I didn't really do my job
properly I think I'd hold my hand up and
say that
one didn't press the most uncomfortable
buttons hard enough
as you describe the arrival of the
Americans you didn't tell us the story
of how that whole statue was itself
manipulated why not the entire live
cameras of the world's press were on the
balcony of the Palestine Hotel
and that was really the only events that
they saw about
Iraq is coming out so it was a sort of
made for TV moment and uh the most
telling moment in that whole
day was when an American Soldier climbed
up
Crane and put the American flag over the
statue's face
because in fact that was
a true iconic moment of what had
happened that America had taken
ownership of Iran
in Britain Blair and Bush's invasion was
applauded as a Vindication of them and
their strategy
he said that they would be able to take
Baghdad without a bloodbath and that in
the end the Iraqis would be celebrating
and on both of those points he has been
proved conclusively right and it would
be entirely ungracious even for his
critics not to acknowledge that tonight
he stands as a larger man and a stronger
prime minister as a result it is
absolutely without a doubt a Vindication
of the strategy of the Vindication for
him those who said
[Music]
should they you know use a MOAB the
mother of all bombs with a few Daisy
Cutters and you know let's not just stop
at a couple of cruise missiles
I've fallen almost in love with the F-18
Super Hornet because it's quite a
versatile plane
[Music]
I got to tell you my favorite aircraft
the A-10 Warthog I love the warthogs
[Music]
the war we don't see in Iraq is largely
the massive toll on civilians in Iraq
where daily even now people are being
killed and wounded because of this
occupation
seeing what I see contrasting that with
what has been reported by most of the
mainstream it's it's like two completely
different worlds
[Music]
in 2004 American Marines twice assaulted
the city of Fallujah the second time
with British forces a nightmare unfolded
the Americans made the city a free fire
zone
the UN reported that 70 of the houses
were destroyed and those standing were
riddled with bullets
thousands of civilians were killed
little of this was shown on the majority
TV networks in Britain and America
that the Americans met courageous
resistance was not news at all
viewers did not get a sense of the sheer
scale of the suffering of Ordinary
People
this remarkable film from inside
Fallujah was made by an American Mark
Manning with Rana yubi and Iraqi it has
never been shown on television in the
wars of today it's often daring
independent filmmakers like these who
give the victims a voice
yeah
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
hang on
American journalist Jamal also entered
Fallujah independently and revealed that
the Americans had used white phosphorus
and attack civilians
his eyewitness dispatches and
photographs contradicted the version
many people saw and read but were not
published in the mainstream media
I have photos of trenches being dug and
I watch them burying people there and
put little makeshift gravestones writing
anything to try to identify the people
and I walked the rows of these stones
after the April Siege with one of my
interpreters while she read
uh old man in track suit with a key in
his hand mother and two children these
were the identifying markers and these
are these are clearly civilians what
does embedding
do to journalists
themselves an important distinction
between embedded journalists and
independent journalists is that when you
choose to embed you're giving the
military the the full power to control
where you go how you get there what you
see and when you see it and in a lot of
instances even how you're going to
report that
hundreds of thousands of people were
forced to evacuate the city
refugees in their own land
they were given nowhere to go many are
still unable to return
[Music]
everyone all right
evidence that the Invaders had
terrorized civilians was provided by Al
Jazeera and other Arab TV networks whose
Fearless unembedded reporters and Camera
Crews became a threat to military
propaganda
they gave voice to people who refused to
be betrayed simply as victims
y
children
here
is
I happen to be I think the only
journalist in the world that has seen
the bombing of Al Jazeera arabic's
bureaus in both Kabul in 2001 and in
Baghdad in 2003.
the case of the bombing of the Al
Jazeera office in Kabul was
without doubt and categorically a direct
targeting of those journalists to shut
them up and
possibly kill them Al jazeered informed
Washington every news organization
provides
um Western military uh commanders with
exact coordinates of where their
journalist side but the point about the
bombing of the Al Jazeera Arabic office
in Kabul was that they were given a
warning to get out
um so that was a clear
targeting of a journalistic organization
and Personnel to get them off the air
journalists who refused to go along with
the military are often those who report
the real news
in August 1945 a public relations
spectacle was staged on the USS Missouri
in Tokyo bay in which general Douglas
MacArthur ostentatiously took the
surrender of the Japanese
the embedded media were told to attend
[Music]
an Australian reporter Wilfred burchard
of the London Daily Express refused
and set out on a perilous Journey for
the ruins of Hiroshima
the official truth of the atomic bombing
was presented in this New York Times
report which claimed that radiation
sickness did not exist the reporter who
wrote the story was later revealed to
have been secretly on the payroll of the
U.S war department
's historic scoop had exposed the LIE
there was he reported an atomic plague
I interviewed Wilfred burchard in 1983
shortly before he died it was I think as
I described it was like a city not a
bomb city right which Steamroller was
going to flattened everything out of
existence what I was seeing there and
this feeling sort of grew into me as I
walked around and I looked at people and
here this is the last minute what
happened in the last minute of uh World
War II it would be the fate of cities
all over the world in the in the first
hours of a World War III what happened
to you personally in Japan after that
was published
um I went back to Tokyo by train and
arrived just as there was a press
conference being held to deny my story
because the official line was that there
was no such thing as atomic radiation
and that that the denial of that story
is going on for decades it's called this
still going on
the media consensus was that the atomic
bombs had brought the war to an end
but official files told another story
a nuclear race had begun and the Cold
War followed
based on the propaganda of fear it was a
war we never saw but was always
threatening
and we never knew how close America came
to using nuclear weapons again
what follows is a secret conversation in
1972 between President Richard Nixon and
Henry Kissinger taped in the White House
[Applause]
thinking big was what the Bush
Administration did in February 2003
this is the U.S Secretary of State Colin
Powell of the United Nations promoting
the invasion of Iraq with an
extraordinary theater of the Absurd Iraq
declared 8 500 leaders of anthrax
but unscom estimates that Saddam Hussein
could have produced 25
000 leaders nothing of what he claimed
was true
all these pictures were meaningless
Saddam Hussein's intentions have never
changed he is not developing the
missiles for self-defense these are
missiles that Iraq wants in order to
project power
to threaten and to deliver chemical
biological and if we let him nuclear
warheads this irrefutable undeniable
incontrovertible evidence today Colin
Powell
brilliantly delivered that Smoking Gun
today it was devastating I mean and
overwhelming overwhelming abundance of
the evidence point after point after
point with he just flooded the terrain
with with with uh data did uh Colin
Powell close the deal today in your mind
for anyone who has yet objectively to
make up their mind
uh I think for anybody who analyzes the
situation
he had closed the deal
Al's incredible performance was never
seriously challenged in the American
broadcast media of which Rupert
Murdoch's Fox television is the biggest
Network
like the rest of the Murdoch Empire it
backed The Invasion we expect every
American to support our military and if
they can't do that to shut up I just
steer this thing I mean there's no I
mean you have a stick is that right sure
we have the uh but the cartoon
journalism of fox can often overshadow
the fact that the respectable media has
played a critical part in promoting War
like Fox the celebrated New York Times
published The False claims that Saddam
had weapons of mass destruction
the paper apologized to its readers one
year later
in Britain The Observer another
respected liberal newspaper published
the same false claims
David you've written about your articles
in the observer in the build up to the
Iraq invasion
that
you feel and I quote you nauseated angry
and ashamed
about what you wrote what did you mean
exactly
it's now
and has been for a number of years very
painfully apparent that uh the facts
that I believe to be true in those
articles were not true they were a pack
of Lies fed to me by a fairly
um sophisticated disinformation campaign
but didn't it occur to you that
these people were professional Liars I
overcame what should have been stronger
doubts I I can make I can make no
excuses I I I I mean you I should have
been more skeptical I mean you've
finished off one of your articles by
expressing almost here little editorial
at the end which you wrote that for the
West Iraq was and I quote an ideal place
to establish a Bridgehead
there are occasions in history you wrote
when the use of force is both right and
sensible this is one of them I mean in
essence you were advocating an attack
yes on a defenseless country that's
quite something isn't it what has
happened the enormity of what has
happened in Iraq is far bigger than you
know my own embarrassment my own
feelings and what happened was a crime
uh it it was a crime on a very large
scale
um does that make a journalist
accomplices
yeah broadly hmm
unwitting perhaps but but yes
this CBS News special report is part of
our continuing coverage of America at
War here is Dan rabbit for 24 years the
most famous news anchor on American
television was Dan Rather
your own career is remarkable for many
things but one of them in that you you
have stood up to power your questioning
of Nixon which I remember in back in 74
and also your interview over Iran gate
with uh Bush Senior
but
then later on you appeared on the
famously on the David Letterman show
which I happen to see and uh
you you you said George Bush is the
president he makes the decisions and you
know as just one American wherever he
wants me to line up just tell me where
and he'll make the call
why did you say that
this was in the almost immediate wake of
9 11.
and that's the way I genuinely felt I
was responding as an American citizen in
a personal way and I have said that
whether
those of us in journalism want to admit
it or not
then
at least in some small way
fear is present in every Newsroom in the
country a fear of losing your job a fear
of your the institution the company you
work for going on a business the fear of
being stuck with some label unpatriotic
or otherwise that you will have with you
to your grave and Beyond
the the fear that
there's so much at stake for the country
that by doing what you deeply feel is
your job will sometimes be in variants
of those all of these things go into the
mix but it's very important for me to
say because I firmly believe it I'm not
the Vice President in charge of excuses
that we shouldn't have excuses what we
should do is take a really good look at
that period and learn from it
and you know suck up our courage Charles
Hanley who won Pulitzer Prize for
reporting was in Iraq in January of 2003
and he went to all the sites that had
been named by Bush officials as
suspicious sites El toetha and Fallujah
he went to every site that had been
named by George Bush Cheney rice Colin
Powell and he found that in every case
they were still sealed since 1991 by
when they had been sealed by U.N
inspectors
he filed a report on January 18th it
went to every major Newsroom in the
United States because it's the AP which
goes to every major Newsroom in the
United States got no pickup no one
published script it didn't fit the
script it got virtually no pickup
it didn't fit the script we were going
to war no matter what I think that if
the good media coverage good journalism
that tells truth the power can make a
huge huge difference so do I think that
we would have gone to war if the media
had done their job and it challenged not
just the lies about weapons of mass
destruction but the lies about how how
Saddam kicked the inspectors out in 1998
and the whole the whole Litany of
propaganda that led up to
you know March 20th 2003 the launch of
the war I think if the media had been
challenging that there's no I think we
would not have gone to war Jeremy Paxman
said last year he and the rest of the
media had been hoodwinked in the run-up
to the invasion of Iraq is that
something that
you would agree with
um well what I think I would say about
that is that clearly
we did not realize until much later in
the day
that the weapons of mass destruction
were not there and of course there was
the so-called dodgy dossier as well so
there is quite a body of evidence to
build up to suggest that the media
certainly were taken in by the claims
that were coming from government at that
point yes why didn't the media get it
why didn't the BBC get it
I think that we didn't get it partly
because of lack of access
if you want to find out what's happening
then you really need to go there and do
some first-hand reporting
uh which wasn't possible in the run-up
to the war in Iraq
but the crucial facts were available the
chief United Nations weapons inspector
in Iraq Scott Ritter gave me this
interview four years before the invasion
in 1991 Iraq had
significant capability in the area of
chemical weapons biological weapons
nuclear weapons production capability
and long-range ballistic missile
manufacturing capability by 1998 the
chemical weapons infrastructure had been
completely dismantled or destroyed by
unscom or by Iraq in compliance with
onshcom's mandate the biological weapons
program had been declared in its
totality late in the game but it was
gone all the major facilities eliminated
the nuclear weapons program again
completely eliminated the long-range
ballistic missile program completely
eliminated all that was left was the
research and development and
Manufacturing capability for missiles
with a range less than 150 kilometers a
permitted activity everything that we
set out to destroy in 1991 the physical
infrastructure had been eliminated
so if I had to quantify Iraq's
threat in terms of weapons of mass
destruction
the real threat is zero none the former
Chief weapons inspector Scott Ritter was
saying as early as 1998 that Saddam
Hussein was completely disarmed Scott
Ritter I think appeared in 2003 twice
and once at three in the morning on BBC
24 news he was a vital expert witness
and there were others
well I don't know why Scott Ritter
didn't appear more but he clearly that's
the question for the BBC why why weren't
those who were those voices heard yes
well because there were also other
voices that we were putting on the air
unscum Mohammed al-baradi Hans Blix so
we were actually listening to to those
voices but yeah I think you've got a
good point you know why why didn't we
it's a question that we asked ourselves
afterwards why was it that we didn't
discover this first uh didn't discover
the state of Saddam Hussein's weapons of
mass destruction I think what what
critics of that would say is that the
broadcasters
notably the BBC
echoed or Amplified the lies told in the
run-up to The Invasion rather than
investigating itself what the BBC though
have a duty to do is to halt what
governments and their representatives
are saying which we of course did we
were just reporting quite legitimately
the claims that people at the time were
making they weren't legitimate claims
though
they were in the mouths of legitimate
leaders though and therefore we had a
duty to report that but those leaders
both of them you mentioned Blair and
Bush
have long been discredited I mean isn't
it the BBC's role as well as reporting
what politicians say to hold power to
account
of course it is it's always it's up it's
the BBC's duty to scrutinize what it is
that people say we're not there to
accuse them of lying though because
that's a judgment no no no that's not
being suggested that you make a judgment
the point is that it appears now that
those important journalistic Challengers
were never made it's not up to me to
make a judgment we're there to report
what their claims are and hold them up
to scrutiny and and investigate in
August 2002 ITV reported a warning by
vice president Cheney that Iraq would
soon have a nuclear weapon the and that
was nonsense
but it was presented uncritically as
news
wouldn't you say that that contributed
to
the The Invasion that happened the
following March what it might have done
but with respect not our fault I mean I
I don't believe that you're suggesting
are you that we should completely
dismiss the words of arguably the second
most powerful man in the Western World
we didn't necessarily agree with it we
reported it and allowed our viewers to
make up their minds as to whether this
was a man telling the truth or not no
but that but that's not fair on viewers
is it because they may not know what we
as journalists know or ought to know
that this was an extremely dodgy
politician who was making is making
extraordinary claims if we knew it we
should have said so if we didn't know it
we can't
and that applies across everything
um but you're absolutely writing one
regard we shouldn't take things at face
value we should do our best to
investigate and when we do know we
should tell our viewers of course we
should that's part of the the process of
being a journalistically based
organization I mean I was thinking of uh
of Blair's many statements one on the
29th of January 2003 ITV news reporter
Blair is saying we do know of links
between Al-Qaeda and Iraq these links as
you know didn't exist I mean we're
getting into the Realms of sort of
semantics now but if you they're very
important he used the word links
between the two your quotation not mine
I think that was the quotation from 19
years yeah
links now links can mean a thousand
things it doesn't necessarily mean a
bond of support links well I I'm sitting
here across you you're telling me that I
would say to you well show me that there
were no links show me that they'd never
show me that even those claiming things
said there were no leaks any
Communications of any kind between those
two organizations come on it's
impossible to do that and he chose his
word carefully and of course well
they're not careful we do know of links
between Al-Qaeda and Iraq but the word
links yeah could mean a thousand things
is the point I'm saying here and you're
not suggesting I'm sure that we
shouldn't have reported what the Prime
Minister was saying you were talking
about semantics a little while ago
well I find it virtually impossible to
believe that Britain could have got away
with the invasion of Iraq
um if the media had been doing its job
when Blair was standing up and saying
our our policy in the region was to
Bolton bolster the forces of democracy I
mean really the proper reaction to that
would have been to burst out laughing
there's simply no history of that at all
Britain has been on the side of
authoritarian repressive regimes they
are our allies the omanis the Saudis the
Egyptians they are our allies not the
the more democratic more liberal forces
in the region and I think that if
journalists had even had a a slight
interest in looking at the history and
in looking at the at what what the
government was actually saying at the
time and what the evidence was at the
time they would have reported things in
such a manner that the government just
would not have been able to have got
away with what they did
Good morning Vietnam welcome to the Don
Buster this was the Vietnam War which I
reported a new military jargon
collateral damage was designed for the
media and to cover up the scale of the
industrial killing of up to 3 million
people and the terror of indiscriminate
bombing often known as turkey shoots
the longest bombing campaign in history
happened here in North Vietnam mostly
unseen from outside
[Music]
this is a photograph of the town of ham
long in the north not a building
remained only bomb craters
pictures like this were sold and
published
Vietnam was the blueprint for the wars
of today murder and destruction replaced
military tactics
almost every man woman and child became
the enemy
Roger
it's time that we recognized ours was in
truth on noble cause
as in previous Wars public memory of the
Vietnam War was greatly influenced by
Hollywood
The Deer Hunter
platoon
Good morning Vietnam
the Green Berets
all these films perpetuated an illusion
turning fiction into truth the theme was
fake heroism and self-pity The Invader
is victim purged of all crime
today a series of Iraq war movies
follows the tradition
the current Oscar winner The Hurt Locker
is the familiar story of a psychopath
high on violence in somebody else's
country where the suffering of its
people
exists
what I saw was a film that was a
complete
uh celebration
of the lone lunatic but who ultimately
you know is the quintessential American
hero because
lunatics are very big in this country
we even elect them presidents sometimes
this film is a film about
killing in which killing is completely
incidental and this is a war that was
orchestrated purely for profit and for
oil and for ownership of other people's
resources and for control of global
resources
a public inquiry into the killing of
Baha Musa and Iraqi Hotel worker has
been told that British soldiers have
tortured and killed prisoners
Phil Shiner is the lawyer acting for
more than a hundred Iraqi families
modern
democracies don't leave marks so stealth
torture
um and so the things that we developed
and we weren't alone the Americans did
the same obviously
a much more subtle leaving someone
hooded putting someone into a wall
standing position depriving of food and
water Etc
my clients complain of every type of
threat that your women will be brought
here and raped in front of you that you
know death threats you'll be transferred
to Guantanamo Bay and frankly people
should be prosecuted for a lot of things
I'm talking about in Criminal Courts not
military courts you can't have soldiers
Prosecuting other soldiers being tried
by a panel of soldiers the court-martial
system in My Views utterly failed that's
that's got to go
you need the people who are complicit in
it all you need them prosecuted what
role do you think embedding plays in
this well the problem with embedded
journalism is all we're seeing is the
point of view of the troops
we're not seeing or hearing from the
civilians who are on the wrong end
of of their tactics so let's take
detention it it seems clear
that British forces in Iraq killed
many people maybe hundreds of civilians
when they had custody of them
and did the most extraordinary brutal
um things involving sexual acts Etc
embedded journalism is never ever going
to get close to hearing the story of
those Iraqis
foreign
[Music]
this is the B1 Lancer bomber which costs
the American taxpayer
283 million dollars each
and this is what it did on May the 4th
2009 in Farah Province Afghanistan
following false intelligence of Taliban
in a village
its victims were some of the poorest
people on earth
guy smallman is an independent
photojournalist and the first Westerner
to arrive in the village following the
bombing
the first strike happened outside the
village mosque which was the first place
that I was taken to was just a mass of
craters and several bombs had fallen in
that area
then after that
um the women and children were evacuated
to a compound in the far north of the
village
and again their heat signatures were
picked up by the Bomber Crew and a two
thousand pound bomb was dropped into the
middle of them and that was where the
majority of the people died
[Music]
first thing that struck me when I was
going in there
was was the silence
I mean the Afghan Countryside is usually
a symphony of Birdsong and it was
absolutely dead quiet and the locals had
done their best
to collect all the bodies and the body
parts but there were still flies
swarming all around the area and there
was still a very pungent smell of death
very heavy in the air
I think the thing that's um
struck me more than anything else was
the children
it was almost as if all their energy and
emotions have been drained out of them
and they would stare right through me
and my translator into the middle
distance
they didn't laugh they barely spoke at
all
and that I think left the most lasting
impression
and I was given quite a a grim tour
of where people were buried in a lot of
cases entire families were buried in the
same grave I think I counted just over
new Graves fresh Graves
and then one far end of the cemetery
there's an enormous Mass grave which is
around 30 meters across
and in that grave or the remains of 55
people and they had to be buried there
together because they were quite
literally blown into pieces and it was
impossible to tell who was who so they
had to bury them together in one long
Trench
and then there was the difference about
the casualties
you know the local people insisted that
over 140
civilians had died and NATO said there
was 25. so the deaths of 147 people
including 93 children became a dispute
over it became dispute over a body count
and nothing more now I know for a fact
that the pitch is taken by the Afghan
radio journalists were out there
I know that string is on the ground
we're filing those pictures and I mean a
lot of those pictures were very graphic
but a lot of them you know did show
people digging bodies out of the out of
the rubble it did show those bodies
lined up for burial
why do you think um British audiences
and other Western audiences
have no real
sense of an atrocity of this scale
I think people become desensitized to it
when they when they're told on the news
a wedding party has been attacked by
accident
a compound has been bombed by accident a
farmer and his family have been killed
by accident
They Don't Really connect with it
because they don't actually get to see
those bodies it faces the names the
names it's just a number whether they're
Afghans or Iraqis
or Lebanese civilians
they're just numbers
and it's perhaps easy to understand why
British Muslims feel completely
disenfranchised from our domestic new
Services I think the Press really
conspires to play Down the Carnage in
Iraq and Afghanistan this gets to what
the Great American writer and academic
Ed Hermann called worthy and unworthy
victims the Iraqis are not worthy
victims so we can play down their deaths
because if we accept the reality that
there are more than a million dead
it's largely our fault
and so for instance the U.S press will
talk about 200 000 to 400 000 dead in
Somalia those victims are worthy victims
because they were killed by people that
we don't like and in one bizarre case
which talked about the cultural
peculiarities of Afghan Society because
they actually got wrangled when you
killed their family members their
civilian family members and in another
case they said that uh
they argued that Afghanistan Afghan
Society was peculiar because they didn't
like people breaking into their houses
in the middle of the night
you know and this caused them to get
angry and sometimes sometimes carry out
vendettas
this is the British Armed Forces
Memorial in Staffordshire
it's not as well known as The Great
cenotaphs and it hauls many secrets
[Music]
there are sixteen thousand names here
every year since 1948 British forces
have been in action somewhere in the
world
and there's space for another fifteen
thousand names of young service men and
women waiting to die
[Music]
what's extraordinary about this Memorial
is its record of constant War during
so-called peace time as if revealing the
secret of Britain's enduring Imperial
role
what's missing is any record of the
victims of these wars the countless men
women and children kill mostly in their
own countries in our name and glimpsed
only now and then on the TV news at
least a million people have died as a
result of the invasion of Iraq they are
not part of our remembrance because
they're not allowed in our memory
Mark Curtis is an historian who writes
on British foreign policy his specialty
is revealing long forgotten official
files
I've certainly uncovered a lot of uh
episodes where Britain has been either
involved in coups or has been involved
in military interventions that have uh
appalling impacts on people's lives that
simply never get mentioned they're never
referred to in the in the newspapers
they never get on TV histories of
Britain
um they uh they're they're just taken
out basically they're deleted from from
our historical memory why does the
public in Britain have such little idea
of the sheer scale of this
well a very large reason for that is
that I mean if you look at every war or
every coup or every regime that Britain
is supporting or been involved in
it's usually accompanied by an
increasingly sophisticated public
relations operation by the government
we're told that British foreign policy
is based on promoting democracy on
spreading development and promoting
human rights well if you read the actual
government planning files planners are
saying to themselves that their policy
is not based on that it's based on the
control of oil it's based on creating an
international economy that works in the
interests of British corporations and
it's based on maintaining their great
power status this culture of impunity is
deeply embedded within British Society I
mean if I if you go back say say in the
1960s a time when Britain was covertly
supporting an Indonesian military that
was killing up to a million people
where Britain was responsible for
depopulating the shagos islands and
where Britain was arming the Nigerian
government that was killing hundreds of
thousands of biafrans in the Civil War
in Nigeria all of that was taking place
under the labor government in the 1960s
and none of those ministers have ever
been questioned and yet those decisions
cost literally millions of lives
[Music]
the attack on Iraq did not begin with
shock and awe during the first Gulf War
in 1991 Britain and America deliberately
bombed Iraq's modern infrastructure
and when the war was over the bombing
continued
this was seldom reported
during this period of the 1990s the U.N
imposed an economic blockade led by
Britain America
Essentials like clean water and vital
drugs were denied
in 1998 the United Nations Children's
Fund reported the deaths of half a
million children under the age of five a
direct result of the sanctions imposed
by the blockade
this is Dennis Halliday former assistant
Secretary General of the United Nations
who resigned after refusing to
administer the sanctions
in 1999 I traveled with him to Iraq the
very provisions of the charter and
Declaration of Human Rights have been
set aside and we are waging a Warfare
through the United Nations on the
children and people of Iraq
results results that you do not expect
to see in a war under the Geneva
conventions we're targeting civilians
worse we're targeting children like
suffer who of course were not born
when Iraq went into Kuwait I mean what
is this about it's a monstrous situation
for the United Nations for the Western
World for all of us who are part of some
democratic system who are at fact
responsible for the policies of our
governments and the implementation of
economic sanctions
Khan Ross was a senior British Diplomat
at the UN responsible for imposing the
Embargo on Iraq
you gave evidence on the impact of
sanctions yes and this is what you said
the weight of evidence clearly indicates
that sanctions cause massive human
suffering among ordinary Iraqis in
particular children we the U.S and UK
governments were the primary engineers
and Defenders of sanctions and were well
aware of this evidence at the time but
we largely ignored it or blamed all
these effects on the Saddam government
sanctions effectively denied the entire
population the means to live unquote
that's that's a shocking admission
yeah I agree well I stand by it today
why didn't you speak out during those
four and a half years there is a certain
Macho culture in foreign policy circles
that to to talk about things like
humanitarian suffering when you're
dealing with Saddam Hussein is a bit wet
you know that it's it's not what the
issue is really about that governments
do security that that's the kind of hard
thing that we're there to provide and I
think however wrong your decisions may
be whatever damage you may do to other
individuals there is at the end of the
day no accountability accountability
whatsoever we had extraordinarily good
resources to put together our story to
find little facts to justify their story
factoids I began to call them and how
eagerly would um journalists accept
these factoids they had very little
chance to do anything other than accept
our version of events and more or less
relay it on unedited to the public
government is an information machine and
we would control access for journalists
to us to governments when I was in news
Department in the in the foreign office
we would control access to the foreign
off to the foreign secretary as a form
of reward to journalists if they they
were critical if they we felt they were
they were too hostile to our account of
events we would not give them the
goodies of trips with the foreign
secretary around the world or you know
exclusive interviews every now and then
we did the same in New York if
journalists were not particularly
supportive to our account we would
freeze them out we would make life
harder for them but there is a subtle
and private relationship between them
which is basically of of you know
favoritism that um certain journalists
are rewarded with access for for being
supportive of the story they will
basically tell journalists you carry on
with that line that that kind of
unjustified criticism of our government
policy on xyl said we will punish you
and that that is very explicit those
kinds of threats what happened was was
not an intelligence based process it was
basically a PR process run by number 10
to to produce a document that was much
more more politically credible than the
evidence suggested it was a major
deception wasn't it I think it amounts
in effect to that yes I remember before
I was sent to New York in late 97 I did
the round of departments in London
saying to them okay I'm going to New
York I'm going to be doing Iraq what do
I need to know and I went to see
non-proliferation Department in the
foreign office and I was expecting a
briefing on the vast piles of weapons
that we still thought Iraq possessed and
the desk officers sort of looked at me
slightly sheepishly and said well
actually we don't think there's anything
we don't think there's anything in Iraq
uh I said that's extraordinary I mean um
I thought we had sanctions because we
thought Iraq had large amounts of
weapons he said no no uh the
justification for sanctions is basically
that uh we have unanswered questions
about how those stocks were destroyed in
the past
but what I feel I mean I feel very
uh I feel very guilty about it I feel
very ashamed about it I feel ashamed
about it sitting talking to you
you know I feel actual shame running
through my body when I talk to you about
it should journalists feel the same
those who pass on the deception
absolutely we should all be accountable
to each other I mean I think that's the
only way to have a civilized society is
some kind of transparency with each
other and accountability and people
holding people morally accountable for
what they do and that applies to
journalists as much as it applies to
anybody
[Music]
these were to be the borders of Israel
and Palestine when Israel was founded in
and this is what's left of Palestine
today fragmented and dislocated by a
military occupation that defies
international law and is backed by one
of the world's most sophisticated
propaganda machines
10 journalists have been killed by
Israeli forces since 1992 and many more
have been wounded
the Pioneer in Glasgow University Media
Group has just published its latest
study on the media reporting of Israel
and Palestine
I think what it comes down to is a basic
knowledge that journalists have which is
quite simply that if they criticize
Israel then it's potentially trouble if
they criticize the Palestinians then
that's there is much less of a problem
so they might use a word like occupation
but they won't say military occupation
they won't say military rule they won't
explain in detail what it means they
wouldn't certainly wouldn't do it
routinely to explain in detail what it
means to be living under military Rule
and why the Palestinians from their
point of view are trying to overthrow
that military or trying to throw off
that control
Professor Greg farlo heads the Glasgow
unit
looking at his research and it come
through very clear it's a certain state
of fear exists on
who the Israelis will complain to they
say in the research people producers
worried will they complain director
General level or will they just simply
Ring The Newsroom but the point is this
sense of intimidation almost
welcome to the world of a correspondent
who has to deal with this pressure on a
daily basis yes where I would take issue
with you is the Fear Factor because
actually no correspondent that I have
come across who is used to working in
Jerusalem particularly or dealing with
this stuff fears it at all I was
thinking of people here at television
Center we don't fear it either we take a
lot of it but we don't fear it after we
did the first book I gave a number of
talks two two journalists in Britain to
BBC journalists and I spent time with
people who were senior producers on on
television news and one of them said to
me in the context of a quite a heated
discussion that was going on with other
journalists he said listen he said we
wait in fear that was his exact words we
wait in fear for the telephone call from
the Israelis he said the only issue we
face then is how high up it's come from
them has it come from a monitoring group
as it come from the Israeli Embassy and
then how high has it gone up our
organization is it the duty editor is it
has it gone above that is it the
director General he said he said I have
had journalists on the phone to me
minutes before we've gone on on a major
news program saying what can I say which
words can I use is it all right if I say
this
on May the 31st 2010 Israeli forces
attacked an aid flotilla headed for Gaza
in international waters they kill nine
people
in the days that followed Israeli
propaganda set out to manipulate the
news agenda they were clubbed they were
beaten
stabbed it was even a report of the
gunfire don't you think it's fair to
to look at some coverage and say there's
a tone
the tone was of course you didn't sit
down and say we're going to put the
Israeli point of view
but the tone throughout was that Israel
had a problem not the people who were
shot in the back of the head but that
Israel had a problem I think there are
two things here
evalued human life
because I don't think we did no I didn't
but I think it's legitimate to ask what
the implications of this were going to
be for Israel which is what that
question was attempting to do
tonight at 10 the Israelis under
pressure after the raid on ships taking
Aid to Gaza hundreds of activists in the
Convoy were detained in Israel including
at least 40 British Nationals they were
pushing everybody and the people running
around and they were hitting us with the
back of their gums the Israelis are
accused of carrying out a bloody
massacre but they claim it was
self-defense
are planning for yesterday's
interception was for a peaceful police
operation our Sailors on the on the job
were told you are to use minimum minimum
force and maximum restraint the top of
the main news was Mark regev
unchallenged Mark regev as you know is
is the chief Israeli propagandist
Mark regev is a spokesman for the
Israeli government now you can describe
him as a propagandist well what else is
he that's but please don't that's a
pejorative way of putting what
government spokespeople are you know
they're entitled to express their point
of view and we have a duty to report it
I'm afraid that their polite view
wouldn't be shared by the families of
the people who were killed on the back
absolutely accept that and we have a
duty to report that that perspective as
well who's the Palestinian equivalent of
Mark reggae who appeared so often who's
the Palestinian equivalent of all those
mainly female Israeli spokespeople
during operation casts lid who was who
was their equivalent articulate in
English given given a space right at the
top of BBC News who is I think that's a
very good point uh you know who are
those people yes well why why hasn't the
BBC but that's not our job to go and
appoint the Palestinian spokesperson
would you say you're impartial surely
you would find somebody to be yes at Mr
reggae of saying his say but then his
equivalent we do and we did you don't
actually you don't have an equivalent of
Mark Greger if that's just not true just
because there isn't an equivalent of
Mark regev doesn't mean to say that we
didn't allow those views points which
you've just expressed to be heard across
the range of our output
this was ITV News on May the 31st using
the same Israeli footage
filmed with night vision cameras Israeli
Commandos dropped from helicopters onto
the deck of a Turkish a chip and violent
clashes erupt
in the immediate aftermath of the
Israeli attack
on the aid flotilla in in June for one
thing the Israelis supplied doctored
film even with captions which was widely
used across ITV in the BBC it was
labeled but it the the the context of
this according to the Israelis that
their people who were attacking the
flotilla were actually being attacked by
the people who were on the Patilla that
that
Israeli perspective
propaganda dominated
well don't get dominated but certainly
the Israeli propaganda machine as you
well know is very very sophisticated and
in its own terms is quite successful on
occasions and yes it is the case that
sometimes media organizations fall into
a trap laid for them by uh it's only
sophisticated because we allow them to
be sophisticated but again you know it's
only when you can come to write the
history of these events that you can you
can see it with that hindsight view what
it's actually happening on a daily basis
you've got to be very careful what you
do when the story is over and when
someone has the time and brain power
left to actually kind of write the
definitive history of it sure then if
you've got things wrong you put your
hands up and you say well at that time
we weren't aware of that we made a
mistake that's that's you know that
happens from time to time people like
the Palestinians can't wait
until someone writes a definitive
history they depends
on journalists well you're suggesting
that journalists can
that the job of Journalism is to change
the world it ain't I gotta tell you even
someone with your massive experience
should know better than that no I'm not
saying that your job is to make sure
that the public who consume our news are
as informed as we can make them so that
they can make their own minds up
but viewers can only make their own
minds up if they're given all the
available facts graphic independent
video was available on the internet on
the night of the attack
four months later a United Nations
investigation described the Israeli
attack as displaying unnecessary and
incredible violence
six people were executed at point-blank
range
the attack warranted prosecution for war
crimes
this was only reported in a 12-second
item on ITV News and completely ignored
on the three main BBC TV bulletins and
seen only on news 24
[Applause]
one of the public relations triumphs of
the 21st century was the rise of Barack
Obama
his campaign slogan was change we can
believe in
he was a brand that offered something
special exciting
in 2008 Obama the candidate was voted
marketer of the year ahead of Apple Nike
and Coors beer
he made many people feel good as if his
slogan might be true
above all the perception of brand Obama
was that he was against War most of you
know that I oppose this war from the
start
I thought it was a tragic mistake
but that was false as President Obama
has not withdrawn America from Iraq and
has backed U.S military action in
Afghanistan Pakistan Somalia and Yemen
and approved a military budget of 708
billion dollars the biggest war spending
of all time
Cynthia McKinney is a former
congresswoman and Green Party candidate
for president
it's a great shame on
the black political tradition
in the United States
to have
a warmonger
it's almost as if
the
black community in the United States
Maybe
we've lost our innocence too
because
um
it would be very difficult to find a
black person in the United States just
an average ordinary person who supports
any of these wars
and yet these wars are being carried out
in blackface
more than any other president Obama has
prosecuted truth tellers known as
whistleblowers
and this is WikiLeaks an internet
whistleblowing organization
independent and stateless it represents
a landmark in journalism
Wikileaks has released hundreds of
thousands of Secret Pentagon documents
that describe the wholesale killing of
civilians in Iraq and Afghanistan
in the information that you have
revealed on Wikileaks about these
so-called endless Wars
what has come out of them looking at the
enormous quantity and diversity
of these military or intelligence
apparatus Insider documents
um what I see is a a vast sprawling
estate what we would traditionally call
the military intelligence complex or
military-industrial complex and that
this sprawling
industrial estate
is growing becoming more and more
secretive becoming more and more
uncontrolled this is not
um a sophisticated
conspiracy controlled at the top this is
a a vast movement of self-interest by
thousands and thousands of players are
all working together and against each
other
to produce an end result which is
Iraq and Afghanistan and Colombia and
keeping that going you know we often
deal with
tax Havens and people hiding assets and
transferring money through offshore tax
Havens so I see some really quite
remarkable similarities
Guantanamo
is used for
laundering people
to an offshore Haven which doesn't
follow the rule of law
similarly
Iraq and Afghanistan I and Colombia are
used to wash money out of the ux U.S tax
base and back arms companies arms
companies yeah I mean what you're saying
is that money and money making
is at the center of
Modern War and it's almost
self-perpetuating
yes and and it's becoming worse what
happens when Wikileaks runs into the
United Kingdom which has
some of the most Draconian secrecy laws
in the world such as the official
Secrets Act
we haven't found a problem publishing UK
information
I mean when we look at the official
Secrets act label documents we see they
state that it is an offense to
retain the information and it is an
offense to destroy the information so
the only possible outcome is that we
have to publish the information
hahaha
um and that's which we have done on many
many occasions I I noticed one that I
had a personal interest in was one that
uh from the ministry of Defense
classified document that um equated uh
terrorists with investigative
journalists as threats and Russian spies
and Russian spies yeah as as in fact in
many sections of that report
investigative journalists are the number
one threat to the sort of information
security of the ministry of Defense so
that was a a 2000 page document on how
to stop leaks from the ministry of
Defense which which we leaked
I didn't know whether to be offended or
honored
well it's nice to be having a
impact
since the release of the pentagon's war
Secrets Julian Assange has been
subjected to extraordinary smears and
accusations originating in America and
Sweden
these include threats against his life
and bizarre character assassination
the media all over the world has
Amplified this propaganda
Secret Pentagon document St
U.S intelligence intends to destroy
trust in Wikileaks by threatening
whistleblowers with exposure and
criminal prosecution thereby
discrediting truth tellers
how you feel about whistleblowers as an
essential part of democracy do you do
you approve of whistleblowers well I
think you know this country has laws to
protect whistleblowers exactly
and uh and I think that you know that
there have been instances in our history
where shining a light on something is is
important to do
can you
as a senior official
of the United States government a
guarantee that the editors
of WikiLeaks and the editor himself is
not American are not in danger that they
themselves will not be subjected to the
kind of hunt that we read about in the
the media well first of all it's not my
position to give guarantees on anything
we do have an open uh criminal
investigation the investigation is
targeted on the individuals that have
um violated the trust and confidence
that's been bestowed upon them by this
country but Wikileaks is an organization
run from outside the United States and
the founder of that has been told that
he is at Great risk from being hunted
down I don't know in what form
and neither do I so I'm afraid I can't
help you
I mean for you to receive that volume of
documentation
suggests that there must be
something of a rebellion
going on within the system
yes I mean it's the one hopeful thing
is in fact there are good people in the
US Military and some of those people
have had enough it's sort of another way
of being a conscientious objective and
in fact arguably a far more powerful
way of objecting to the war
when the soldiers on the ground he
describes the atrocity as and I quote
him an everyday occurrence and he said
the word from his Commander
was to kill I won't use the word
everyone on the street and he replied to
him are you kidding me women and
children he said yes and it's a point
made by many other soldiers who've come
back from Afghanistan Iraq that this
kind of atrocity is not an aberration
well first of all this is not an
everyday occurrence if it was an
everyday occurrence we would certainly
know about it
these incidences are unfortunate
everyone in which there's a civilian
casualty is is unfortunate but again it
is the enemy who is deliberately trying
to inflict civilian casualties and put
civilians in harm it is the NATO forces
it is the U.S forces that are taking
every precaution that they can to
prosecute the war and prevent civilian
casualties General
James Cartwright who's Vice chair of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff
he says the United States
can expect to be at War
and these are his words for as far as
the eye can see
that sounds like a permanent state of
War our job is to be prepared to
um
fight and win this nation's Wars and so
we have to be prepared for the
possibility of conflict into the future
it's a remarkable State of Affairs isn't
it because the United States
is not in fact threatened by a power
that could possibly overturn it defeat
it
that's impossible but still it goes on
as if we're all drawn into
most of humanity into a permanent state
of War for many people that seems very
difficult to justify
well first of all there are some very
dangerous asymmetric threats that are
out there terrorism obviously one of
them
this is what we what we anticipate going
into the future is is not necessarily a
nation on Nation type conflict okay it
is these asymmetric threats that are out
there it's the threat of
um
of weapons of mass destruction is
there's been another asymmetric threat
is the Cyber threat that exists these
are all threats that transcend
um geographical boundaries
so you know the United States military
has to prepare for a wide range of
threats that exist out there in order to
protect its national interests
on media drums beating for another War
say a war with Iran I wouldn't say that
the media are beating the drums for for
war yet although they are showing the
same credulousness
the same obsequiousness towards the
powerful as they did in advance of the
Iraq War I'm not sure it's to the point
that they're beating the drums for war
yet but when the elites decide it's time
to go I would be surprised if they did
anything but you've mentioned already
Iran yeah and there is an enormous
choice to be made about Iran a more
developed more formidable more populous
and certainly better armed country than
saddam's Iraq whatever was are you
actually saying that we should threaten
them militarily if they are determined
to develop nuclear weapons I am saying
that I think it is wholly unacceptable
for a round of nuclear weapons
capability
and I think we've got to be prepared to
confront them military necessarily
militarily if necessarily military I
think there is no alternative to that if
they continue to develop nuclear weapons
and they need to get that message loud
and clear does this sound familiar
there is as much evidence that Iran is
building nuclear weapons as there was
that Iraq had weapons of mass
destruction as claimed by Tony Blair
we know that great falsehoods were
perpetrated and yet the individuals who
perpetrated these things are still
running around you know more or less
much as before you know being taken
seriously as commentators as authorities
on this or that you know I find it
astonishing these people should hide
their heads in shame
the British Elites do not want the
public to know what they're doing they
don't actually even think they have a
right to know what they're doing
um and and they know that the more
information the public has the more
difficult it is for them to pursue
policies that maybe are abusive of Human
Rights or involve supporting a
repressive regime and so there's a
conscious strategy actually of having
these public relations campaigns that
the government regularly has whenever it
resorts to an overseas military
intervention to try and convince the
public that they're acting in uh for the
highest of noble intentions when in fact
they're not when when they're usually
acting out of hard-hearted
straightforward calculation of elite
interests
so the public is a threat that needs to
be counted
for too many journalists the price of
their independence is their life
they include Terry Lloyd of ITN shot
dead in Iraq by American Marines
since the invasion of Iraq more than 300
journalists have been killed
more than in any other War
this film is a tribute to them
that doesn't mean that we journalists
have to risk Our Lives to tell the truth
but we do have to be brave enough to
defy those who seek our collusion in
selling their latest bloody Adventure in
someone else's country
that means always challenging the
official story however patriotic that
story may appear however seductive and
Insidious it is
for propaganda relies on us in the media
to aim its deceptions not at a far away
enemy but at you at home
it's very simple
in this age of endless Imperial War the
lives of countless men women and
children depend on the truth
or their blood is on us
never believe anything until it's
officially denied said the great
reporter Claude Coburn in other words
those whose job it is to keep the record
straight or to be the voice of people
not power
house in the Hollywood Hills with a
trunk load a hundred thousand dollar
bills man came by the hook of mine cable
TV we settled in for the night my baby
and me
enough
57 channels and nothing
[Music]
well now home entertainment was mine
babies wish so I hop in town for a
satellite dish
tied it to the top of my Japanese car
came home when I pointed out into the
Stars
the message came back from the great
beyond
just seven channels
57 times